Africa that SIA is visiting her house
near the outskirts of Mexico City it's
the home she used to share with her
husband and three children two years ago
a massive earthquake split opened the
ground underneath the property due to
the threat of the structure collapsing
authorities told Africa she would be
relocated to a government home that new
home however as well as thousands of
others promised to earthquake survivors
never materialized
it's exasperated to live outside your
home
we've organized marches meetings and
roundtables with government
representatives it's the only way we've
seen any solutions but it's not enough
the emergency here isn't over the 2017
earthquake claimed hundreds of lives in
the Mexican capital and the surrounding
states thousands more were displaced as
homes and buildings were toppled or at
least severely damaged once the dust
settled the Mexican government announced
that 800 million dollars would be set
aside for reconstruction
but little is actually known about where
much of that money went and transparency
advocates warned the problem isn't
isolated to this one natural disaster we
are a very unique country honest in the
sense that we have a lot of hurricanes a
lot of earthquakes and we need to be
better prepared for the mitigation and
the adaptation for for disasters the
Mexican government still lacks a
mechanism that tracks emergency spending
this is a matter mexico's president has
promised to correct
we estimate that by the end of 2019 we
will have 40% of reconstruction
finalized hoping to be completely
finished by the end of next year public
records show a majority of
reconstruction funds were allocated
toward public school buildings homes and
historic monuments most of the rubble
may have been cleared but there's still
plenty of reconstruction to be done here
in the Del Mar neighborhood near the
eastern end of Mexico City there are
still fissures in the streets places
where the ground sank by nearly one
meter and there are still dozens of
damaged homes that have yet to be
demolished
Africa Garcia says she'll continue to
pressure public officials to act but she
says she knows many other earthquake
survivors who have given up many
metropoli
al jazeera Mexico City